only after the crown you get recognized
a lot more now when you going to a party
I did yeah it was we're in the shop and
we're on the way to a party and I was
like I need to just pick up some vulka
so I picked up a big bottle of vodka and
I was like what mixer I just have I
don't know I couldn't decide so I just
had the bottle of vodka and I cracked it
open I was like swigging it down as I
swinging it down this girl walks past me
clocks eyes with me I think maybe
because like the the drink and the sort
of expression on my face and like the
combination she sort of was like
Princess
Margaret I went not it's not it's not
what it looks like so method yeah right
it was like this like slower eye lock
which was like oh my God it's all true